(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] It's a
surprisingly dangerous mission,
safely navigate the
skies of one of the most
iconic tourist destinations in America.
(rushing water)
The helicopter pilots of Niagara Falls
battle extreme wind and
unpredictable weather conditions,
all to give tourists that
one spectacular view.
- [Stanley] Sometimes it is very scary.
You try not to let the fear over come you,
so you can control the aircraft,
you get it back to a safe environment,
so you can go home at night.
That's the name of the game, go home.
(laughs)
(water flowing)
(upbeat music)
My name is Stanley Snopkowski.
I've been flying over
Niagara Falls about 20 years.
And each day is different.
I spent 20 years in the military.
I've flown in Germany, England, Vietnam,
and the weather here is
nothing like anything else.
(intensifying string music)
(helicopter whirring)
Niagara Falls is beautiful.
But like anything beautiful,
there's a ugly side to it.
The weather here can change quite rapidly.
You can have snow showers,
and five minutes later,
you can have bright sunny blue skies.
You have to have a healthy respect for it,
because it can go wrong
in a matter of minutes.
The winds can gust up to
30 to 40 miles an hour.
When the wind comes around the buildings,
it tends to create mechanical turbulence,
either an updraft or a
downdraft, or swirling.
And then sometimes when you make the turn
into the wind, it's almost sometimes like
hitting a brick wall.
I've had instances where
the aircraft wanted
to come apart, quit flying.
And we nursed it down to the ground.
We got down and we and walked away.
And it could have ended up differently,
without the training,
without the knowledge.
(laughs)
I sometimes think that Mother
Nature's not my friend today,
because of the winds or
because of the rain or snow.
You deal with that,
and hopefully come out on the good end.
Or the other thing is, is you just sit there
and you say, okay, you win today.
I'm not going to fly.
(laughs)
I look at the falls and I
see the beauty of nature.
Some days, after a major
storm comes through,
the air is so clear.
You have maybe 100 miles visibility.
And it's just awe inspiring
to be able to see all that,
and, uh, see the falls from a different angle.
I just love it.